- You know, it's not like just
'cause you love football or
hip hop or roses that
you're entitled to build
a million dollar
business around that.
Passion is
massively importantly,
I'll tell you why.
Work ethic is an absolute pillar
of variable to being successful.
And if you're
passion about something,
it doesn't feel like work.
And that's a big deal.
If you feel like if you're
working on your side hustle from
6 to 2 in the morning,
6 P.M., 7 P.M.,
right, and you're not up for
it like you're forcing yourself
because you need
the money or the dream.
You've fucked up.
You picked the wrong thing.
To punt all your leisure and all
your friends and family and to
work on something and to be
tired the next day 'cause you
have to get up for work which
you really don't want to do
which is why you're
building your side hustle.
That has to be
about your passion because
it's too hard if it's not.
It can't be
about where you think
you can make the most money.
What I don't think people
understand is you can make a lot
more, like there's a lot,
so I wrote Crush It!
a long time ago.
The emails that I get, I get way
more people that are making 50
to 200,000 a year
talking at the craziest,
like the emails
I get are so bananas.
Like, well banana's in my
Snapchat so I won't use that.
Like, "Hey, GaryVee,
you know, I read Crush It!
in 2009 and I'm making
$74,000 a year
in ads and selling T-shirts
around raspberry jam only.
(audience laughter)
I've had a lot more
people make money deep,
deep, deep in the
longest tail niche that
you could have ever thought of.
Hip hop stars from 1986 to 1989.
This is a real one.
There's a guy who only talks
about hip hop from '86 to '89
'cause he was in high school
during those years and now he's
like now he gets paid like five
to $10,000 a month retainer to
do hip hop consulting for
companies that came from the
content he was putting out.
- That's so amazing.
- He stopped
being an accountant.
(audience laughter)
Right?
But the people
that are losing are,
I tried to build an
affiliate marketing company.
I tried to do $500 e-books.
They went for the money,
they had no patience.
The hip hop guy and the
raspberry jam girl and this guy
had years of nobody
giving a shit before we popped.
I did Wine Library TV for two
years with not, with crickets.
Crickets.
- What kept you
going during that time?
- 'Cause I knew I was right.